thank you while those hotels are
struggling to find workers so
many businesses are still suffering from
the devastating
impacts of lockdowns
it's been a really tough time for the
industry it's been for a while we've
done
everything we can to get ready small
businesses in california
and and what they've done it's it's
unthinkable
and to me it's a humanitarian crisis
right now we're just trying to make a
dollar here and it's uh very difficult
i know i can speak for all these other
restaurants also
we're fit we're done but don't tell
that to the la times which claims
lockdowns didn't harm the economy at all
look at that headline right there
here to react fox news contributor and
media opinion columnist for the hill
joe concha joe good morning happy
thursday steve how we doing
we're doing okay although uh it's pretty
clear the la times is in la la land
we just heard from the small business
people that the lockdown
strangled them and yet this writer is
trying to say
no harm to the economy yeah and look
this is an opinion piece it's not a news
story
and opinions are like i can't say that
it's like derrieres or
everybody has one we'll put it that way
but in this case
this is one of the stupidest things i
have ever read because it ignores
hard data and numbers let's look at the
numbers shall we
in california where the la times is
located the unemployment rate is
currently at 8.3 percent
let's compare that to a state that's
basically been opened for the last year
in florida under governor ron desantis
where the unemployment rate is 4.7
so you're talking about a a big shift
there overall steve
8 million jobs have been lost since the
pandemic began we haven't gotten those
back yet
so to say that covet lockdowns have
actually not hurt the economy
particularly in california where a third
of the restaurants there
had been closed or two-thirds of
restaurant workers lost their jobs at
one point
it is a profoundly stupid argument to
make
no kidding and i'm sure every one of
those small business owners that we
spoke to and have spoken to would agree
with you
joe meanwhile i don't know if you saw
but the president united states was
at the graduation for the coast guard
cadets yesterday
and after he made he delivered joe biden
delivered the exact
same line that ronald reagan delivered
to the exact same audience about 30
years
earlier but as you're about to see we're
going to put the sound bites back to
back
as you can see one person
did it and got a big laugh and the other
person
was shocked at the reception here they
are
presidents reagan and biden
my coast guard aids have been excellent
one of them taught me that
and i quote the coast guard is that hard
nucleus about which the navy forms in
time of war
i can only assume that you will enjoy
educating your family about how the
coast guard is quote
the hard nucleus around the navy forms
in times of war you are
quite you're a really dull class
come on man okay uh
reagan was a uh a television performer
and a movie star
yeah the it's all about the presentation
it's
all about the delivery and uh i guess
how would you grade the two interesting
reagan made that
speech in 1988 that was the same year
that joe biden ran for president had to
drop out because he played your eyes so
just a
little aside there uh quickly yeah
reagan a
uh biden d minus in that case but biden
you don't think a great sense of humor
when it comes to the 46th president
there's the same guy who said quote you
can't go to a 7-eleven or dunkin donuts
unless you have a slight indian
accent and i'm not joking one said of
barack obama quote you've got the first
sort of mainstream african american who
is articulate and bright and clean
picture republican saying that and
actually surviving win valuable prizes
steve well you know
and after joe biden kind of botched the
delivery then he
then he attacked the audience he said
you're a really dull class
yeah memories of uh jeb bush and please
clap
right ladies and gentlemen joe koncha
please